pero asumió la presidencia pro témpore
de la comunidad andina de naciones en
este país se realizó la emitidos a la
reunión del consejo presidencial andino
en la declaración de la cumbre los
mandatarios de perú ecuador colombia y
bolivia acordaron avanzar en la
consolidación del sistema andino de
integración que promueve el desarrollo
de los países miembros reactivar la
economía de la comunidad andina para
mitigar los efectos de la pandemia del
cobi 19 entre otros acuerdos en esta
cumbre motivó el primer viaje
internacional del presidente gustavo
petro fuera de colombia en la cumbre el
mandatario invitó a descarbonizar la
economía de los países de la comunidad
andina de naciones mediante la
protección de las amazonas y la
reindustrialización
usado petro también propuso discutir a
nivel regional el tema de las drogas en
esa línea pidió a los países miembros
convocar a una conferencia regional en
la que se discuta la política común ante
la realidad del fracaso que ha supuesto
la guerra contra las drogas durante más
de medio siglo esta realidad en palabras
el presidente de petro merece que en la
cancha se convoque a una conferencia de
países centroamericanos sudamericanos
para discutir la política de drogas
analizarla sopesar la con los números el
mandatario colombiano
puso énfasis en que el flagelo de las
drogas no sólo afecta a colombia sino
también a los demás países de la región
lo que ha causado que a pesar de que no
haya ninguna guerra en sudamérica esta
región del planeta posea alguna de las
ciudades más violentas del mundo